before the video starts guys i've come
together with muslim mate once again to
get to clean water
for families in gaza 105 pounds can
provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year give even if it's
one pound towards it
there is because you're putting a limit
but when it comes to lgbtqt
and there's plus there's many other
things there's it's open but when and
also for example pedophilia
there are some men who are coming out
and saying that they why can't they join
your group and add a p at the end
you're making about gender rather than
age we're not necessarily talking about
people we're making those statements
because people
hurt other people but they say we were
born like that
that's the argument not me that's what
this
like we're not just talking about that
kind of thing we're talking about people
who are
uh being discriminated for the gender
they love not necessarily the age
the gender i'm with you if a murderer
says
they want to kill someone else and
they're just like that you're not going
to let them kill someone else
you're going to do everything you can to
stop them from hurting someone else
same with pedophiles if someone says oh
i was just born like that and they want
to hurt someone
you need to stop them from hurting
someone lgbtq people
aren't hurting anyone in fact we're the
ones being hurt by other people
okay no i understand that but what i'm
saying is this this can be argued for
example hurting what does hurting mean
you're not hurting someone physically um
or having a harm in a society as a whole
the ripple effects of that that's
something that needs to be discussed
because
if one says argument's sake when i drink
alcohol
i don't hurt anybody but you're the same
person when you're drinking alcohol you
go crash into a car
with uh kids in there and you kill so
like in islam as muslims islam is
prevention better than rather than cure
so meaning
if alcohol if one person says i want my
right to drink alcohol islam says no if
you're going to have a
impact a negative impact on the
community you can't do that because the
community at large has a greater right
but what i was asking you guys look i'm
not trying to attack you guys i'm
curious yeah
but when i see inconsistency i have to
you can do the same with me
when you draw a line with the pedophiles
when you draw a line with incest
i'm asking the question for example the
pedophile movement that's bestiality
even yeah
they they want to join your group they
even like you know there's some
discussion where they're like
why can't and the lgbt group are denying
that they say no you can't but they're
saying we're born this way why is it
that when you're born a gay
homosexual bisexual the transsexual
whatever it may transgender whatever
you're born you have a right but as a
pedophile when i have
some kind of um liking to a child and
even some of them say even if we don't
act on it
i have that except me as i am you just
reject them
because they're hurting people they we
are not incest that's the main
difference
what about incest a father and a
daughter that's reached age of 16 they
use contraceptives
yeah but that as we said that father is
in a position of power over the daughter
like do you respect your father okay
what age does the child need to reach so
they're not in a position of power
because because there is no age that
they raise because they're in a position
but that could be with anyone that could
be with two gay couples and one is
has a position more manipulative over
the other person in gay couples if one
of them is abusive then that's wrong too
but if a woman comes and says i'm 16
years old my my father is not
manipulative and i choose the right to
have sexual intimacy with him
how could you come and say no he's your
father he must be manipulative you're
over generalizing
how's that fair on them and their love
he's manipulative we're not saying he's
necessarily
100 manipulative we're saying that that
person is in a
position of power over the daughter
correct
do you like acknowledge that that person
they they are until that person reaches
the age of puberty 16 because they have
they have they have a lot of rights you
know they can call the fed in two
seconds
okay can i ask why how is this relevant
because what it is is what we're just
trying to do is that what i'm trying to
find out is because i feel like there's
an inconsistency with the lgbqt
community
um and this is where um where i'm saying
well there's a contradiction that's what
i'm trying to highlight and i'm trying
to tell me if i'm wrong so that's why i
was
trying to have a dialogue with you guys
because it seems a contradiction
to your very stance let me ask you the
opposite question why
do you draw this straight line at men
and women being in relationships
and not at all people of any genders
being in relationships
us we come from an objective morality
where we believe god almighty has
created us
and we live in his land and he provides
us the sustenance
and what he says we try our best to
follow now obviously like
as muslims in this country we abide by
the law of the land yeah
um so you guys can like i'm not here to
stop you doing what you're doing but
what we're trying to say is for example
from our point of view it's for example
we believe
that god almighty has forbidden it it's
not permissible
yeah and not only that for example there
there are many issues as well for
example
it's unnatural i believe it's unnatural
even though you can say okay there's an
animal kingdom
but i can i can say that's animals but
what i'm saying is unnatural for a man
for example uh to penetrate another
man's uh
rectum you know and and and that's from
our point of view but but i'm not i'm
not i'm not saying you guys don't have
to i'm sorry we didn't consent to being
filmed
so if you're broadcasting this they they
do like could you please
take that down yeah whoever is recording
your face
okay yeah you're not using
nothing okay all right guys whoever is
recording this
they don't want to be in here yeah
because the speaker's gonna you get ten
cameras i can't control them
yeah so you can leave i just want to
make one more
one question so our position i'm just
going to sum up in one
in one okay so you say that god
said that it's not okay and that's fine
like i completely respect your opinion
from our perspective it's okay for any
adult consenting person who does not
have
a parental or like familial relationship
with someone else
it's okay for them to have a
relationship lgbt this is uh
society stand with the words you said or
is this coming from you the the whole
parent
the the whole parent the whole parents
will think of being manipulative
that's the first time i've heard that
most people within the lgbtq community
do not endorse india for example is it
because the whole manipulative thing
because that's the first time i've heard
that
well it's partially because of that it's
also partially because genetic it's for
a lot of different reasons
and i obviously haven't i haven't
prepared for this we're just here for
that
we haven't prepared this i couldn't tell
you every argument but we don't endorse
incest and all we're saying is that
anyone who's
over a legal age of consent should be
allowed to have a relationship with
anyone else and that's fine you're a
really nice guy thank you thank you very
much i'm so sorry again if
i'll just inquire thank you very much
enjoy yourself okay thank you yeah just
read this nice dialogue here discussion
uh just ask some questions i think it
was quite informative uh yeah
goodbye